Một hành hành hành hành hành hành hành hành hành hành hành hành xấu trên khu vực hủ thức bà, giá bảo ái, tình lào cài, sẽ ra vụ lịch tổ chở hết hình xấu với mất tích.
Ngay trong đêm, nhận được lệnh của cấp trên về việc cơ động lực lượng đi tình kiếm nạn nhân mất tích vụ lịch tổ.
Lứ đoàn đặt công hải quân một hai xấu đã hình chương làm công tác chình bị điều động lực lượng.
Phong tệ đi tình kiếm cướng nạn, lứ đoàn đã đều động hành hình đồng chiến đa công hình hãy có kinh nghiệm của mấy lạc sâu.
Sù cứ là, máy nên khi và nhiều loại chá tiết bị cứu nạn khác, từ hài phòng cơ động đến hộ thức bà để tổ chức tình kiếm các nạn nhân mất tích.
Đến bà dựa bà bị phút hôm nay, lực lượng cứu nạn của lưới đoàn đã có mặt tại hình chương và cơ động ra bị chiến tình kiếm.
Tự ta phạm ngọt tân anh, khó lưới đoàn trường lưới đoàn một hai xấu, chức tiếp chỉ vì lực lượng tình kiếm của đơn vị cho biết, hiện tại quốc hồ thức bà xương mù dây đặc, mưa nhỏ.
Hồ có độ sâu lưới nước khoảng mấy bà emét, đêm sâu giờ bố 15 phút cùng ngày, các tổng người nhá của lưới đoàn đã tiết hình lạn kìm tra trong thân tàu hình lịch và tình kiếm các nạn nhân ở các quốc hực xung quanh.
Đến bài giấu 15 phút cùng ngày, lượng lượng người nhá của lưới đoàn đã có được phía thiệm một nạn nhân lại cháu hòn nước mạnh, sinh năm 2018, ở thuân một giá cả nhân tình lào kai.
Hình các tổ đoàn của người nhá của lưới đoàn tích tuộc khoanh cùng về tình kiếm các nạn nhân còn lại.